I have to uh take a step back I have to
correct something I previously said
in the past
I have been talking about Democrat Josh
Shapiro Josh Shapiro is the guy running
for governor in Pennsylvania Josh
Shapiro is running against Doug
mastriana
and in the past I have been saying about
Josh Shapiro not as a pejorative but
I've just been saying Shapiro is a
completely uncontroversial milk toast
boring Democrat and I've been saying
that in a positive sense that what I
mean by that is the options for
Pennsylvania Governor are extremist
January 6th attending big lie repeating
right wing ideologue Doug mastriano who
will steal Pennsylvania's electoral
votes in 2024 if he gets the opportunity
that's that's one choice and the other
side is a completely boring
uncontroversial milk toast Josh Shapiro
who is just going to be very under the
radar and run the state of Pennsylvania
in a completely normal boring
uncontroversial way and I was saying it
as the choice should be obvious we need
Josh Shapiro Josh Shapiro over the
weekend appeared with Barack Obama
and delivered an absolutely fantastic
speech Obama level speech went
completely viral millions and millions
of views and I was wrong
I don't think there's anything milk
toast about Josh Shapiro he actually
seems like a fantastic candidate
you know this guy loves to talk a good
game about Freedom right let me tell you
something it's not freedom to tell women
what they're allowed to do with their
bodies that's not freedom
it's not freedom to tell our children
what books they're allowed to read
it's our freedom when he gets to decide
who you're allowed to marry I say Love
Is Love
it's not freedom to say you can work a
40-hour work week but you can't be a
member of the Union that's not freedom
and it sure as hell isn't freedom to say
you can go vote but he gets to pick the
winner
that's not Freedom critical issue that's
not freedom but you know what you know
what we're for we're for real freedom
and let me tell you what let me tell you
what real freedom is
real freedom is when you see that young
child in North Philly and you see the
potential in her so you invest in her
public school that's real freedom
that's real freedom
real Freedom comes when we invest in
that young child's neighborhood to make
sure it's safe so she gets to her 18th
birthday that's real Freedom yeah I I
have to tell you
super impressed with Josh Shapiro over
the weekend here's one more clip of Josh
Shapiro talking about his opponent
[Applause]
this is a guy
it's a guy who doesn't respect women
here in Pennsylvania
in fact in fact in fact if you don't
think like Doug mastrian if you don't
look like him if you don't vote like him
if you don't worship like him if you
don't marry like him you don't count in
his Pennsylvania
[Applause]
you know how I know that
because I know where he was on January
the 6th right
he went there that day understand
understand he went there that day not to
hear his speech or protest he went there
that day to stop your vote from being
counted Josh Shapiro is really good I
actually you know I was feeling like we
just need to dodge a bullet by
preventing Doug mastriano from becoming
the governor of Pennsylvania and we do
but I actually the more I learn about
Josh Shapiro and the more I read about
his policy platform and ideas I think he
will be a fantastic governor of
Pennsylvania he should win it is not
close right now in the polling but
everybody should vote a former president
Barack Obama also very clearly
explaining the stakes
the only way to make this economy Fair
the only way to make our democracy
stronger is if we fight for it you can't
take it for granted and that starts with
electing people who know you
who see you
who care about you
who can walk in your shoes and see
through your eyes and know what it's
like to struggle know what it's like to
get sick know what it's like
to have to pay off student loans know
what it's like
when things aren't just handed to you
but you got to work for them
that's what you did two years ago when
you sent Joe Biden to the White House he
knows you he's been there he's fighting
for you every day doing everything he
can to put more money in your pocket to
make streets safer to bring more good
paying jobs here to Pennsylvania so
listen later you'll hear the types of
things that were being said at the Trump
rallies over the weekend but this is not
an election about whose policy do I
agree with slightly more okay this is
fundamentally about
which candidate agrees
that the winner should actually get to
do the job
and there are a lot of these people
running who are perfectly fine even if
their opponent gets more votes saying I
should still be the governor I should
still be the senator even though I
didn't get more votes and that's
extraordinarily scary let me know your
thoughts leave a comment on YouTube and
by the way if you're not subscribed to
the YouTube channel make sure you hit
that subscribe button at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show before you
go if you enjoyed this video and want to
see more please make sure to subscribe
to my YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
Pacman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description